there's considerable anxiety about the
direction of stock prices at the
Stuttgart exchange for example a false
report that the bank of china was late
in repaying a loan triggered a sharp
decline around the world in late June
Michelle Beck watched it happen for many
years China's central bank handed out
huge amounts of money and very low
interest rates commercial banks lapped
it up and lent out much more too much
without due caution in principle and
it's but it is a lack of transparency it
looks like the central bank has woken up
to the fact that there is a credit
bubble and is no longer willing to
support the system with unlimited
liquidity which is what is happening in
Japan where the markets are being
flooded with money and which has been
going on in the United States for years
now a further problem is that the
Chinese banks have started losing trust
in each other it's rather like during
the layman brothers crisis team included
German companies will also feel the
pinch of the situation deteriorates
further in the Chinese banking sector
Trump is a high-tech company based near
Stuttgart that makes among other things
machine tools China is one of its major
markets Trump also has a number of
production facilities there
mattias Camilla is in charge of the
machine tools division he can't say
whether business in China is set to
decline but over the past decade sales
there have grown to about ten percent of
the company's total you know this email
I English dated sign we always have to
be prepared things can change for
example if credit dries up or state
funding is cut but we're in a position
to deal with that because we offer our
customers financing packages with which
they are no longer dependent on banks
Trump also aims to find more customers
in China at this point sixty percent of
its sales are within Europe total sales
amounted to 2.3 billion euros in the
2011-12 fiscal year the association of
mechanical engineering firms in this
part of southwestern Germany baden
vuitton bag is pretty pessimistic about
their prospects in china at the moment
oh if himani heads the association which
represents 800 companies what's being
fished in what we are seeing is that the
upswing we expected is not materializing
last year our exports to China decline
twelve percent but we thought they would
bounce back once the new leadership
there was firmly installed but that just
isn't happening what about its comptes
evening worries abound about a new era
of lower growth in China and a new
financial crisis some economists say
China has to change its monetary policy
markets may have calmed down again but
the crisis is definitely not over
Hans bethe Birkhoff holds the chair and
banking and financial services at the
University of hohenheim the fact
Sheena's eens all looks like a financial
crisis is brewing in China on the other
hand the government has the means to
influence events to slow down or speed
up the economy as it sees fit so the
problems are to some extent being staged
by the central bank as a purge of the
market that's why everyone's so nervous
because some players will be pushed out
which is to say some Chinese banks may
well go under probably smaller or
medium-sized ones the effects on the
world stock markets will not be pretty